nuevamente las autoridades de hong kong
cargan contra un medio de comunicación
pro democrático unos 200 policías
allanaron la sede del diario star news
para investigar un supuesto caso de
distribución de material servicios ohl y
detuvieron a seis miembros y ex miembros
del portal de noticias web entre ellos
al editor jefe en funciones patrick lahm
desde el medio sin embargo defienden su
trabajo
stand news está haciendo reportajes
profesionales no hay duda al respecto
todo el mundo lo ve no importa qué
cargos se hayan hecho nada puede cambiar
esto aunque la causa de todo no han
causado bendigo asisa durante varias
horas las autoridades incautaron
numerosos material periodístico para
agregar su línea de investigación apunta
hacia una supuesta violación de la
polémica ley de seguridad nacional por
parte del medio que en los últimos años
se ha mostrado como uno de los más
críticos contra la presencia cada vez
mayor de beijing en la política japonesa
el soft cualquier que intenta hacer uso
del trabajo de los medios de
comunicación como herramienta para
perseguir su propósito político u otro
intereses contraviene la ley hunter
pence trono practicada la ofensas
particularmente los delitos que ponen en
riesgo la seguridad nacional son los
elementos malvados que dañan la libertad
de prensa that's timer transferida este
es un nuevo caso en el que se investiga
y detiene a miembros de un medio de
comunicación pro democrático de sant con
el cierre del periódico apple daily en
junio de este año marcó un antes y un
después en el ataque a la libertad de
prensa en la antigua colonia británica